i'm sorry to disturb you albus but i've
just received troubling news it's
grindelwald it is a volatile time in the
wizarding world
dumbledore has to
recruit a team if we're to defeat him
you have to trust me we're seeing many
of the old band back together but there
are some new people
mr scamander we got a glimpse of lally
played by jessica williams in the last
movie grendel valdez at the cemetery
tonight and you gotta go we get to
introduce jess in a great way in a
bigger way you really see her play
and shine
[Music]
professor lally hicks she's amazing she
is a charms professor and i think
because she's known dumbledore for a
long time actually has an easier time
trusting him without knowing really what
the endgame is
dumbledore picks people who have a good
heart and he also picks people who have
very specific talents
and i think it's interesting that she
teaches charms because it's like i'm
gonna activate a to get b to happen
when force won't work it's about using
her brain and really trying to charm out
of a situation
jessica's a comedian and an actor
apologies so she just brought a vibe
that i really enjoyed you do know i'm a
witch right and she's a big potter fan
it's a story and world that's been
imprinted in my life since childhood
on some level you always imagine
yourself in the wizarding world and
that's kind of the charm and the magic
of the books this
idea that you could be
magical and i know it's like that for so
many people
everything about it feels like it's
returning home
[Music]
you